[Música]
al final del invierno los bosques de
arder aún parecen dormidos sin embargo
la actividad nula
la primavera es el momento en el que
toda una población se activa para
estudiar conservar y acondicionar los
espacios naturales
este bosque comunal del parque original
de los montes de arder es administrado
por los agentes de la oficina nacional
de los bosques
la pista está aquí saldría suelo que se
ve detrás de los vehículos se ubica en
el límite de las parcelas
los guardas forestales se preparan para
elegir los árboles que habrá que abatir
la extracción 350 metros cúbicos están
previstos y los frondosos por supuesto
los frondosos no se tocan
es la herramienta indispensable el
martillo forestal que permite martillar
y permite designar los árboles que serán
elegidos para la venta y el corte
no se trata de cortar todo o cualquier
árbol
los agentes forestales buscan y
martillar únicamente los pinos marítimos
una especie invasiva que frena el
desarrollo de las variedades locales
como el pino salzman
miró hacia arriba pinos marítimos que
están encima de los dos pinos salzman y
entonces voy a tomar por lo menos te
molesta más con el leñador tendrá que
cortar arriba de la marga
cada árbol contiene el sello de la ong y
su diámetro es registrado
soy johnson
estos pinos serán cortados de aquí a
unos meses y serán vendidos entre diez y
quince euros el metro cúbico
a batir para regenerar mejor las
especies pero también sembrar de nuevo
donde es necesario
aquí las 80 hectáreas se evaporaron el
verano pasado los agentes forestales
siembran de nuevo 500 árboles
[Aplausos]
los obreros siembran los pinos salzman
que hicimos crecer el vivero tienen dos
años
así como para la tala se privilegia la
variedad local
esto es un poco el pino de la región
luego está la conservación de la
biodiversidad es una especie clasificada
a nivel natural 2000 a nivel europea
aunque entonces está en listas de
protección las colectividades y otros
organismos públicos deben conservar esta
especie secos a veces está espeso
en francia solo un cuarto de los bosques
son públicos
el resto le pertenece a propietarios
privados
compré bosques para recoger castañas y
contar con mi madera de calefacción me
parecía muy simple somos hombre 3 luego
me di cuenta de que era una gran
responsabilidad tener parcelas
forestales de porcel focas y donde
quería ser propietario de un pedazo del
planeta que se hace con ellos
confirmarlos
la primavera es el periodo en el que el
propietario forestal hace injertos
[Música]
implantan jóvenes castaños salvajes una
variedad local que le gusta
esta es la variedad que quiero injertar
se llama guyana las castañas como las
cerezas las manzanas y todas las frutas
tienen variedades diferentes esta tiene
mucho gusto
cada año recolecta hasta 6000 kilos de
castañas
a unos cuantos kilómetros de aquí estos
voluntarios tienen la delicada misión de
señalizar los caminos de paseo antes del
verano
[Música]
y la señalización no es muy clara por la
lluvia el viento y las intemperies
pintan de nuevo la señalización borrosa
gusta lo suficiente porque este año es
difícil de señalizar todo el tiempo
porque porque si se frota mucho el árbol
sufre
es el color de un xerez región gran
caminata de región amarillo arriba rojo
abajo
y paramos aquí hay un riesgo la gente
corre el riesgo de equivocarse y seguir
derecho al riachuelo puede ser peligroso
entonces como se pasa por aquí
pondremos una cruz no sería mejor
ponerla en un árbol
para mí no es normal debiste haber
tomado en cuenta la opinión de los 6
debimos haber votado tampoco vamos a
votar qué es esto una revolución
una cruz que le brinda seguridad al
lugar
en este departamento hay siete mil
kilómetros de caminos a los que hay que
hacerles mantenimiento el bosque es un
tercio del territorio con los días
soleados acogerá a 500 millones de
visitantes en francia tal como cada año